So, you have been invited to a five-star restaurant,...
...and it may sound really fancy.
Let's take a look at some tips to know what to do.
Hi, I'm Hazely Lopez from Hazely Academy of Refinement and Modeling...
...and I'm here to talk to you about how to behave in a five-star restaurant.
Well, you first may want to take a look at the menu before you actually get to the table.
You wanna make sure that you're kind of familiar with,...
...what you're gonna be eating in that night...
...that's going to make it a lot easier to actually talk to the server...
...when he comes and gets your order.
You also wanna make sure that you make reservations and arrive early to them.
Busy five-stars can be a little bit difficult to get in.
You also wanna make sure that when you're eating,...
...you put your napkin on your lap and once you're done,...
...excuse me, before you're done,...
...if you need to go stand up and you go to the bathroom,...
...you leave the napkin on your chair.
This will help the server know that you're not done.
If you are done, you may set the table; you may set the napkin on the table.
Also, you may want to ensure that you order appetizers.
When you're in a five-star restaurant,...
...it is expected to order appetizers.
At the same time if you're ordering a wine,...
...you better make sure that you ask for a suggestion.
There are no returns for an open wine, unless there's something wrong with it.
Also remember that "host eats before you do".
So, make sure you give them that opportunity.
I'm Hazely Lopez from Hazely Academy of Refinement and Modeling...
...and I hope you enjoy your dinner at a five-star restaurant.